depressive ärzte führen alle wege nach
rom und was beinhaltet der neue
klimavertrag das in drei der fünf themen
in den kriegs und pfeifen es heute fast
jeder zweite deutsche erkrankt
statistisch gesehen am krebs das robert
koch institut und die gesellschaft der
epidemiologischen krebsregister haben
einen neuen bericht über die
krebserkrankung in deutschland
veröffentlicht laut des berichts krebs
in deutschland bekommen 43 prozent der
deutschen frauen und 51 prozent der
deutschen männer im laufe ihres lebens
eine krebsdiagnose gestellt viele dieser
erkrankung seien allerdings auch
vermeidbar dem bericht zufolge tragen
viele der betroffenen eine mitschuld in
dem bericht heißt es die tat nach
schätzung des zentrums für krebsregister
daten waren 2008 insgesamt etwa 15
prozent aller krebserkrankungen in
deutschland dem rauchen zuzuschreiben
zitat ende
zu wenig bewegung und ungesunde
ernährung können das krebsrisiko
steigern
stress und umweltgifte seien allerdings
überschätzt was ihr krebspotenzial
angehen würde
bei vielen krebserkrankungen sind die
ursachen allerdings immer noch nicht
vollständig geklärt
die kleinsten clownfische der welt auf
einem bild schweizer forschern der eth
zürich und des unternehmens kroner das
von der hochschule unterstützt wird ist
es gelungen das kleinste farbe der welt
zu drucken es hat eine abmessung von
0,00 92 quadratmillimetern die seiten
länge beträgt gerade mal 80 mal 150
mikrometer dieses bild das ist so winzig
dass es mit bloßem auge nicht sichtbar
ist so der ehemalige eth forscher
patrick calegari die maße des bildes
sind mit der querschnitts fläche eines
menschlichen haares vergleichbar und das
hier ist dieses kleinsten der welt
natürlich vergrößert damit wir sehen
können was darauf abgebildet ist das das
winzige bild dennoch so real aussieht
das liegt einen sogenannten quantum dots
auf deutsch quantenpunkten das sind
nanopartikel die in den farben grün blau
oder rot leuchten
legt man diese übereinander entstehen
verschiedene farben die intensität der
leuchtkraft die lässt sich auch
beeinflussen dieser technik und aufgrund
der farbbrillanz sollen in zukunft zum
beispiel bildschirme produziert werden
mit ihrem winzigen clowns spiel sind die
forscher übrigens im guinness buch der
rekorde gelandet depressive ärzte dass
ärzte einen stressreichen job haben das
ist seit längerem bekannt
dazu gibt es zahlreiche studien auch die
arbeitsbedingungen werden derzeit nicht
besser von den ärztinnen und ärzten
werden oft enorme leistungen abverlangt
einem fachmagazin jama veröffentlichte
studie der harvard university zeigt dass
im durchschnitt 28 8 prozent der medizin
absolventinnen und absolventen unter
stark belasten depressiven symptomen zu
leiden haben dabei beginnt nach dem
studium erst noch die langjährige und
stressige ausbildung zum facharzt hier
müssen die mediziner beispielsweise im
schichtbetrieb arbeiten werden schlecht
bezahlt und tragen dennoch die
verantwortung für patientinnen und
patienten
die wissenschaftler haben für ihre
metastudie 54 vorliegende studien aus
den letzten 50 jahren unter die lupe
genommen
in diesem wurde der zustand von fast
18.000 ärzten begutachtet aus den
ergebnissen haben die forscher den
mittelwert gebildet für die patientinnen
und patienten hat der zustand der erste
ebenfalls auswirkungen die versorgung
verläuft bei ärzten mit depressiven
symptomen tendenziell schlechter ab und
die fehlerquote steigt an
die autoren der studie fordern deshalb
dass es schnellstens reformen geben
müsse um die lage der jungen mediziner
zu und medizinerin natürlich zu
verbessern
alle wege führen nach oben altbekanntes
sprichwort aber wer hat denn schon mal
überprüft ob das auch wirklich stimmt
designer aus stuttgart haben sich das
auch gefragt und wirklich beeindruckende
bilder geschaffen von 500.000
startpunkten aus haben sie den weg in
die italienische hauptstadt
aufgezeichnet hier sehen wir die wege in
europa und je dicker so eine ader ist
desto mehr verkehr herrscht auf diesen
straßen in amerika ist ihnen übrigens
aufgefallen dass es zehn weitere städte
gibt die rom heißen also haben sie auch
die wege dorthin aufgezeichnet ja und
wir hier sehen könnt das sprichwort
lässt sich auch auf jede andere stadt
übertragen
hier führen die wege nach berlin
neuer klimavertrag soll die welt retten
am vergangenen samstag wurde in paris
der ein neuer klima- vertrag
unterzeichnet ein meilenstein alle 195
teilnehmen staaten haben das abkommen
dass 2020 in kraft treten wird
unterzeichnet bundeskanzlerin angela
merkel äußerte sich folgendermaßen so
der unterzeichnung zitate mit dem heute
verabschiedeten klimavertrag hat sich
zum ersten mal die gesamte
weltgemeinschaft zum handeln
verpflichtet zum handeln im kampf gegen
die globale klimaveränderung zieht am
ende aber was genau steht eigentlich in
diesem abkommen auf der webseite der
bundesregierung findet ihr die
wichtigsten punkte und drei der
wichtigsten die stelle ich euch jetzt
4.1 in einer begleitenden entscheidung
wird das versprechen der industrieländer
festgehalten ab 2020 jährlich 100
milliarden dollar für arme staaten
bereit zu halten
diese summe soll bis 2025 fliesen punkt
2 die staaten setzten sich das ziel die
erderwärmung im vergleich zum
vorindustriellen zeitalter auf weit
unter zwei grad celsius zu beschränken
sollen anstrengungen unternommen werden
den temperaturanstieg bereits bei 15
grad zu stoppen
punkt 3 viele entwicklungsländer etwa
die inselstaaten sind durch den
klimawandel bedroht der meeresspiegel
steigt dürren und unwetter werden
häufiger heftiger ihnen wird im pariser
abkommen unterstützung zugesichert etwa
durch frühwarnsysteme und klima
risikoversicherung in der theorie sieht
das ja ganz nett aus wir sind mal
gespannt was haltet ihr davon ist die
euphorie um den klimavertrag berechtigt
ist das ein schritt zur besserung lasst
uns darüber in den kommentaren
diskutieren und wenn euch das video
gefallen hat lasst bitte einen daumen
nach oben da das hilft mir nicht
vergessen klicks um kostenlos abonnieren
das nächste klicks um science-fiction
video natürlich schauen ist in jedem
fall spannend und bis dann bleibt dran